When we did our analytic
analysis of the constraint
conditions between the
accelerations of objects 1
and 2, we came up
with the condition
that a1 was equal to minus 2 a2.
Now let's do something which
we call a virtual displacement
argument.
Suppose that b and 2 move
down a certain amount.
Let's imagine-- and I'm going
to draw in a different color,
too-- so we have object 2,
and pulley 2 has moved down.
Now, this object has
displaced by distance delta
y 2, which is also
equal to delta y
b because they're connected.
Now, what happens when
the system does that,
is our rope has to extend
downwards around this pulley
and come back up.
And that means that
the rope that object 1
has been foreshortened
by not just delta y2,
but on both sides,
delta y2 and delta y2,
object 1 has displaced
up by that amount.
So we'll just make
this so we can draw it
in a reasonable way.
So what we see here
is that delta y1 is
equal to-- now notice, if
2 goes down, by delta y2,
then delta y1-- which
is this whole distance--
is a negative quantity.
And it's going upwards.
And so we see that
that's minus 2 delta y2.
And if we took two
derivatives-- or displacement
and then look at the
change in displacement--
we would see that this implies
that the acceleration of 1
is minus 2 a2.
But let's come back to our
two conditions for length
and see the same thing here.
Because delta l2
is 0, this tells us
that delta y2 is
equal to delta y d.
So we'll write minus equals 0.
And that was our condition
that the block and 2
were moving together.
And up here, we see that,
because delta l1 is also 0,
this implies-- and now I'll make
that substitution that delta
y b is equal to delta
y2-- that 2 delta y2 here
and here plus delta y1 has to
be 0 coming from that piece.
And so we see that delta
y1 is minus 2 delta y2.
Which is what our
virtual displacement
argument showed us.
And again, if you take
two derivatives here,
we have that recall that,
in the simplest way,
that the velocity is dy1 dt.
And the acceleration, a1,
is d squared y1 dt squared.
Then, this same
proportionality is maintained
under the two derivatives.
And that's another
way of thinking
about how to get
the relationship
between the accelerations.
But you have to be extremely
careful about that sign
because this 2 goes in
the positive direction,
1 will go in the
negative direction.